before we move on to finding the
solution of a quadratic equation let's
quickly review how quadratic polynomials
first factorized the general form of a
quadratic polynomial is ax squared plus
BX plus C here's the first quadratic
polynomial here a will equal 1 B will
equal 7 and C will equal 12 one of the
ways in which we factorize two
polynomials was by splitting the middle
term the technique was easy we first
write the coefficient of the middle term
as the sum of two numbers n1 and n2 and
the two numbers are such that their
products equals the product of a and C
so can you think of two numbers such
that n1 plus n2 is 7 and n1 times n2 is
equal to 12 yes 3 & 4 3 plus 4 is 7 and
3 times 4 is 12 so this polynomial can
be written like this the middle term
after expansions will look something
like this what we've done here is split
the middle term 7x was written as 3x
plus 4x and how does this help after
expansion we group the terms like this
and how does grouping help we look for
common terms in each group in the first
group X is common and in the second four
is common so this can be written as x
times X plus 3 plus 4 times X plus 3 now
in this polynomial X plus 3 is common to
both terms taking this common factor out
from both terms we get this so this
quadratic polynomial was factorize today
the two factors of this polynomials are
X plus 3 and X plus 4 if you understood
this concept of factoring polynomials
then finding the roots of quadratic
equations is very easy now assume that
the quadratic equation we have is x
squared plus 7x plus 12 equals 0 and we
need to find it through
by roots we mean the value or the values
of X which satisfy this equation to find
the solutions or the roots all we need
to do is factorize the polynomial on the
left as we've already seen how its
factorized we can write this as X plus 3
times X plus 4 equals 0
now I want you to think of it logically
when the product of a and B is equal to
0 what can be imply we can say that at
least one of them will be 0 either a or
b will be 0 if we apply the same concept
to disk we can say that either X plus 3
equals 0 or X plus 4 equals 0
transposing the constants to the right
we can say that x equals negative 3 or x
equals negative 4 these are the roots of
this quadratic equation if you
substitute any of these values in this
equation you will see that the equation
is satisfied if things have stitute
negative 3 in place of X we get a 0 and
it's the same with negative 4 these two
other roots of this quadratic equation
now why don't you try finding the roots
of this quadratic equation
you should get the roots askew and
negative three so the method that you
saw was finding the solution of a
quadratic equation bus factorization we
factorize the polynomial on the left and
equated each linear factor to zero if
there any other technique to find a
solution of a quadratic equation we will
see that next
[Music]